hi everyone i'd like to thank the
organizers for giving me the chance to
talk to you today about our work with
using machine learning to try to
understand the dynamics of activity
across the brain
so brain activity occurs at many
different scales um we have things that
are happening at the level of synapses
very tiny um organized into layers and
columns and then into these larger
networks like say salama cortical
networks or sensory motor networks and
even widespread modulation of the
activity of the whole brain by
neuromodulatory systems for example
and these also happen at different time
scales you know things can be on the
order of a millisecond for some of these
really fast transmissions and um action
potentials or we might be talking about
changes that occur over minutes or hours
or even days or years if you're looking
at how
the larger scale activity of the brain
might vary with changes like experience
so
all of this stuff is meshed together
into the resting state fmri signal that
we use to map functional
connectivity now we like fmri
because it does give you whole brain
coverage it's non-invasive it has
reasonable spatial and temporal
resolution
even though it's not directly sensitive
to neural activity so we're kind of
getting this integrated and filtered
signal that tells us something about
what's going on
with the neural activity inside the
brain
and the type of data we get is large by
nature so from any given subject we have
tens of thousands of fossils maybe even
a hundred thousand for high resolution
studies
and often thousands of time points
now the way that we usually look at this
data and have over say the past 20 years
or so
is to do something that i'm going to
call time average functional
connectivity
and that means that maybe we take the
brain and you can do it on a voxel by
voxel basis or you can also take the
brain and divide it up into different
parcels so areas that
are kind of functionally similar
and work together
so that we can reduce that spatial
dimensionality of the data that we have
and then you can look at
the relationship between the signal from
each of those areas over time with all
of the other areas
and you get something that looks like
the correlation matrix that's shown on
the right side of the screen
so each of the rows here is an area in a
given network each of the columns is
another area in a given network
and of course the signals from
the signal of an area in a network is
highly correlated with itself and so you
see that along the diagonal but you can
also see these blocks of correlation
where our parcels have been organized
into networks that exhibit high
correlation within the networks and then
you can also see interactions between
different networks that you see in these
blocks off the diagonal where some
networks work together and are
correlated and other networks kind of go
in opposition to each other and are
anti-correlated
so
what what's wrong with this nothing it's
a great way to summarize data but we
lose so much when we go to average
measurements of functional connectivity
so we're taking say if we're talking
about the human connectome project data
we're taking a hundred thousand fossils
six thousand time points per subject a
thousand subjects
and we can condense all of that into one
single matrix of 360 by 360 parcels that
describes the average functional
connectivity across all of these people
so
that's that's a great start but we're
losing all of the information about time
varying activity and we know that
different things are happening
in the brain over the course of the scan
you know even if you're doing a task
your mind wanders away from the task if
we're looking at resting state studies
as we often do you might be thinking
about different things you know maybe
you're thinking about
uh where you want to go on vacation and
then all of a sudden you say well i've
been in the skin for a long time isn't
it time for lunch yet
or you might be in there getting drowsy
or progressively more uncomfortable over
time and all of these things can
influence what we see in the brain's
activity
we know that if we look at this time
varying
interaction between areas that we
measure with time varying functional
connectivity we see relationships to
behavior
and i've cited one paper here that was
an early one from my own group but there
are many many papers now
showing that these
time-varying interactions in the brain
are relevant for behavior and for
um
looking at how
brain activity changes and neural
disorders for example
so we need to find ways that allow us to
capture the dynamics of the whole brain
as a complex system
the current approaches for time-varying
analysis are mostly based on
kind of variations of you know our
average functional connectivity with the
very simplest being sliding window
correlation where instead of taking the
activity
and looking at relationships like
correlation that persists for the entire
length of the scan
we chop that scan into segments
maybe 30 second segments maybe 60 second
segments
and we calculate correlation for each of
those segments and then we can move that
segment along or that window along
and see how correlation between those
areas varies over time
another option that i'm going to talk
about more later is looking for repeated
spatiotemporal patterns that we call
quasi-periodic patterns or qpps and
these are basically
detected using an auto-regressive
algorithm that goes in and looks for
things that happen over and over during
the course of a scan
another common approach is to look at
co-activation patterns or individual
events in this case you're looking for
times when the activity in a certain
area or group of areas passes a
threshold and trying to average those
together and see what else activates
with those particular areas
and all of these approaches are often
followed by clustering to further reduce
the data
and make it more interpretable
so
these have had a lot of success we've
seen a lot of differences within and
between patient groups for example
but i think
that
they all assume particular models of
what's going on within the brain and i
think we still have room to improve
and try to create better models to help
us
better analyze the spatiotemporal
dynamics of the brain from this complex
systems perspective
so one of the things that we tried is to
just use dimensionality reduction
on resting state brain activity to try
to map it to certain states
we did this partly because we've done
simulations that show looking at the raw
data is usually closer to the underlying
signal than looking at sliding window
correlation
and so what we did was assume that each
scan is one time point in the highly
dimensional space
and then we do this t distributed
stochastic neighbor embedding t-sne
algorithm which basically takes this
high dimensionality space and mounts it
onto a low dimensionality space 2d here
using gradient descent and i've got a
picture of a fruit fly over on the side
because we were inspired to do this by
gordon berman at emory university who
uses the same technique to look at
classifying behavior in fruitwise so we
like to think of this as describing
brain behavior
so what we actually did is to take all
of the hcp data including the task scans
the rest scans we had 446 volunteers
from the data set we used and each of
those had 8 680 time points
we took that data to reduce the spatial
spatial dimensionality we ran
independent component analysis
and we took 50 components
from that ica
at the same time we found you know
through basically trial and error that
we needed to expand the frequency
representation of these signals and so
we applied the continuous wavelet
transform
to those 50 ica components to kind of
tell us more about what frequency was
doing what at what time
and that's the data that we threw into
the t-sne algorithm
so on this slide at the top left i'm
showing the latent space that we got as
the output of t's knee
for the rest scans and the task scans
shown separately in a and b
and
what we thought was really interesting
is that there's not a lot of overlap yes
i mean you can see overlap with the task
and the rest which is not too surprising
really because
rest is kind of an unconstrained task
but i like that rest is not merely
a sum of all of the different tasks that
you do you see a lot of states present
in rest that are not there in the task
scans you know which suggests that
there's something that's maybe a little
bit different about doing resting state
analysis
than any of these particular tasks at
least
so along with you know how
different um patterns of activity are
distributed in this latent space
where i should remind you that bright
colors here mean that many many time
points
have been placed in the same area
meaning they're very similar
and so those show up as bright spots
um
looking at the same bright spots and the
bottom we can also calculate
how long um a person tends to spend in
any one of those spots
and so high velocity here is shown as a
bright yellow color low glossy is red
and what you notice is people tend to
stick in those high amplitude
areas that we're really calling states
and they move quickly through areas that
don't really have defined states both
for task and rest so that all makes
sense
now if we look at these latent space
distributions and consider them as kind
of like topographical maps right so if
you imagine that these
high density areas that show up in
bright yellow and in the top row
correspond to high mountain peaks
and
things that are blue correspond to low
valleys you can use this watershed
algorithm to segment different areas
from that distribution and that's what
we've done in the middle column and then
you can pick a particular section of
that that we're calling the state
and outline it in pink
and
shown next to it at the far right
is the
um
wavelet coefficient
as a you know as a function of frequency
there so the wavelet decomposition for
that particular state
and you see that for this state at the
top we have a little bit of
lower than average power and some of the
low frequencies whereas for the state at
the bottom we have high power in the
very low frequencies and low power in
the higher frequencies so we can see
distinct patterns across these states
and i'm just going to kind of go through
this quickly i don't want to take too
much time we can separate this out by
task and you see different patterns for
different tasks we also find that the
decomposition is very reproducible
across
scans when we had multiple runs for
example first addressing state and
second resting state
now one of the things we found very
interesting is that if you look at you
know time point by time point within a
particular task you can see differences
um that kind of suggests there might be
these trajectories of activation within
the brain
so here we're looking at two different
components of the um
of one of the tasks with random dots one
where the dots move randomly and one
where they kind of move in a coordinated
manner which we've
labeled as mentalizing on the top
and we can see slight deviations as the
task progresses in the probability
distribution
for those two
types and if we look at the brain states
shown up at the top right we can see
that the main difference between the two
is in the very low frequencies in the
visual cortex but this pattern looking
at now the bottom left this pattern of
kind of progression across the latent
space
gives us a hint that there might be
trajectories in the brain
so when we started thinking about
trajectories the first thing that came
to mind was that maybe we could use a
variational autoencoder
now these are network architectures that
are widely used to take a signal
you force it through a bottleneck where
it's represented by a handful of latent
variables and then you reconstruct those
latent variables through
a symmetric network to try to
recapture the original signal and the
idea is that this gets rid of noise in a
lot of situations so you're trying to
de-noise a signal
using a variational auto encoder
what we were interested in was whether
those latent variables in the bottleneck
can actually capture
fundamental spatiotemporal trajectories
that serve as the building block for the
resting state fmri signal
so
i'm showing here an early approach where
we only use eight orthogonal latent
variables in our reconstruction so you
can ignore the probability distribution
on the left but if you look at the right
now what we've done is encode resting
state fmri from a single individual
during a single scan
where
red is at one end purple is at the other
end and so you're seeing the temporal
progression
of that scan through this latent space
and there again are hints of a
trajectory and i think you can kind of
see you know there's this tendency to go
along the diagonals from
lower left to upper right from upper
left to lower right and maybe that's
something we can pull out
so we ended up using the auto encoder
architecture that i showed as the
example and that we
found by some empirical tests that 32
latent variables worked fairly well
and so when we took the human connectome
project data and fed it through this
auto encoder and then looked at our
latent variables we got some things that
i think are very interesting
so
it's difficult to describe these latent
variables so
inherently they inherently have
dimensions of space by time
and each point has some weighting of
these variables
so the way we've chosen to show them is
for this particular display
we are showing the facial
components
each network
each parcel from each network is a row
and we're showing its activity over time
blue was lower than average activity
yellow is higher than average activity
and basically we've
gotten these plots by setting each
latent variable to its maximum and zero
zeroing out all of the others and then
looking at the reconstructed signal
and so
if you look at the top row you see a lot
of variability over time
in the second row there's less and as
you go down these explain less and less
of the overall variability in the signal
what we also found is we've looked at
the distribution of the spatial
variability for each one of these latent
variables and there should be 32 here
and so if you look
across space which means looking at a
column you'll see a black line for each
of these and that shows where we see the
most variability across the networks at
one time point
and so what we did
is cluster these variables by how
similar their spatial profiles at that
time of maximum variability were
there are a lot of ways to do this this
was just for kind of display purposes
and characterization
i should also say that by comparison
to other data analysis techniques we
found that the first row looks very much
like our primary quasi-periodic pattern
which also has ties to the primary
functional connectivity gradient second
cluster looks like the second functional
connectivity gradient so there are kind
of external validations for these
so here's the same thing now we are
showing for each cluster the spatial
distribution as we go from
a negative value of that particular rate
in variable to a positive value and so
you can see the spatial similarity
really clearly because we're only
showing this now at the time of maximum
spatial variability we indicated in the
previous slide
we can calculate the functional
connectivity
within each of these spatiotemporal
trajectories and we've done that along
the bottom so you can get a feel for
how how different those patterns are
and then in this last one we're showing
the timing of activity and a single roi
that we've picked
and so now you can see along the
vertical axis we have
the value of the latent variable and
along the horizontal axis we have the
timing so you can see for example even
though this first row has common spatial
profiles we actually have very different
temporal behavior for these different
latent variables
so we're very excited about these and
you know
this work is so ongoing i think we have
a lot of things we can do
to explore how well these characterize
resting state fmri data
but i want to have a little time to talk
about another approach that we're using
which is trying to understand the brain
as a complex system and people have been
doing this for a long time and a common
tool that they use is a brain network
model and the way you get one of these
is you take
a graph that describes the network
structure of the brain which we can
obtain for example from
diffusion-weighted fmri
and at each of the nodes each of the
parcels that we make in the brain we
drive it with a set of differential
equations that describes a particular
neural mass model and there are many of
these
and from that we can simulate resting
state fmri data and see how well we
recapitulate features that we see in the
systems level empirical data
now i mentioned that there are many
different models you can use and in fact
one of the problems i i think with this
approach is that many models and many
different parameterizations
give the same
general average functional connectivity
that we see empirically so we needed a
way to
try to
sensitize our analysis a little bit more
and we did that by adding time varying
metrics
again i don't really have time to go
into this too much but i mentioned the
qpps before
so if you look at the top left graph
that's what our qpp looks like from
empirical data and you can see there's
kind of this positive correlation the
negative correlation and area switched
between the two
compared to the brain network models and
we've looked at two different ones here
the firing rate at the
top right and the
choromoto model at the bottom left you
can see both of them catch this
two-state solution but you don't get
this complex propagation between areas
that shows up as a sort of um smeary
pattern in the resting state fmri data
now we did find that the pattern that
you get from these brain network models
depends on
your coupling parameters and so that's
evidence that this dynamic metric is
sensitive to the types of
parameterizations we use and might help
us do a better job
so we we thought we needed a new
approach we have dynamic metrics that do
a better job but we still have those
huge space of parameters that need to be
swept for each model and so it seems
like a great application for machine
learning
and we've we've taken two different
approaches for this and i am going to
walk you through those pretty quickly
here
so the first one is instead of using a
parameter sleep suite let's learn the
initial conditions
and so for this we use the network
architecture based on a long short-term
memory network in lstm which is a
recurrent neural net
and we put in a certain amount of the
data
and
fit that to one of these brain network
models
and tried to use our lstm to estimate
the initial conditions
at the end of that block of data from
the end of that block of data then we
can integrate those differential
equations and see if our path follows
our data
so here it's demonstrated on a spiral
data set where we know exactly which
differential equations were used to
generate the data
and so you can see we do a pretty good
job of fitting it based on those initial
points that we've learned
here we wanted to show that this is also
sensitive to the structural network that
you use
and so at the top left we show the fit
we get when we use the actual
the correct structural network for this
particular
system
and then at top right and bottom left
we're showing the fits that you get if
you use the wrong network
and as you would expect we um
you know we have the same initial
conditions so things start out good but
they diverge from the real activity over
time if we use the wrong structural
network so they are sensitive to that
okay so how does it look when we apply
it to resting state data that's
empirical
well we tried looking at accuracy
as a function of the global coupling
strength that we built in to the model
and what happened was
that the accuracy actually went down as
the global coupling strength went up and
that's shown on the graph on the left
so you know global coupling strength is
usually set to about 0.9 um
when people do parameter sweeps and
that's our worst performer so we
realized what was happening is that
putting any
structural constraints on the data
actually makes it perform worse this is
supported by the fact that if we use
just the lstm
which is um the second point from the
right and that graph
we actually do better than we do with
any structural network at all
so we had another idea
and we thought okay well let's see how
it responds if we mess up the structural
network
and so
um
on the right we're showing the accuracy
when we permuted
um
we've kept only 10 percent of the
original edges of the structural network
and permuted the rest
all the way up to keeping a hundred
percent of the structural network
correct and you can see if we have a low
global coupling parameter like at the
top
we don't really distinguish across these
cases it doesn't matter what we do to
the structural network but if we go to
the high coupling parameter as you see
at the bottom right we start to see this
different as we go
towards that correct structural network
that we think might help us
be more sensitive to which is the right
parameterization to use
so we're very excited about how this is
coming and we think this is going to
help
maybe avoid some of those parameter
sweeps
okay another thing that we can do
so that last approach we learned the
initial conditions and then we
integrated from there that the lstm was
no longer involved
so if you're off on your initial
conditions you're going to
slowly diverge from the signal that
you're trying to model
so what if we update those initial
conditions every time
and so that's what we've done with this
approach
um here we we do the same thing where we
take an initial chunk of the data we put
it through the lstm
we
predict the initial conditions
from there we feed those initial
conditions
we integrate those initiative conditions
to the next point feed it back into the
model
and then do it all again and so what we
get out of this model
is a time course of initial conditions
for each time point of the scan
and so this is actually pretty cool
we've done this with two different
models the firing rate model and the
wilson cohen model and you can see if
you look at the graphs on the left
that the estimated and measured resting
state mri are quite similar
you can also see this in the middle
we're showing
the time course for each of the
different parcels and how well it's
predicted
based on
this lstm model compared to the original
measured measured signal
but what i think is really excited about
this is now we get estimations of
underlying features like excitatory and
inhibitory activity for example with the
wilson cohen model
that we can pull out separately from
this resting state mri data
so i think that will be very cool
so i mentioned before you know that
dynamic
analysis methods really give us the best
distinction between different models and
so we looked at the qpps again this time
from a brain network model that's shown
at bottom left and should look similar
to before you see the two-state solution
the empirical data one is shown at the
top left
and then we've looked at qpps and the
output from these lstms using either the
firing rate model for the middle or the
wilson coen model
on the right at the top
and what you see is that we're starting
to catch some of that more complex
propagation from area to area that we
couldn't get out of that original brain
network model so we think that this is
going to help us fit our data a little
more precisely
so both of those projects are still
clearly ongoing but i think um i'll stop
there with a quick summary i think
machine learning holds huge potential
for helping us to get the most out of
these enormous resting state mri data
sets
and maybe this is a way to get rid of
some of those parameter sweeps maybe
it's a way to make them more accurate
but most of all i think that machine
learning lets us have a data driven
approach that might help us discover new
things
like these latent spatiotemporal
trajectories that we might be able to
use to explain
what's going on in the brain and that
gives us a new way to think about how
activity might be organized across the
whole brain
of course there are always bad things to
go along with the good and i think it's
important not to do just a blast bot's
application of machine learning
where you may not get something that you
can interpret
and
you know i'm sure um
other people will talk about the need to
be careful with the data you know if you
put junk in you're going to get junked
out and you know sometimes i feel like
the enthusiasm for machine learning
gives us a lot of papers that are
published but are very hard to interpret
in any meaningful way
now i i said you know we shouldn't use
machine learning as a black box i think
we've got to tie it to something that we
can interpret and then that makes it a
very powerful tool for us
so some of the things that might be
possible or multimodal measurements
maybe behavioral performance
and of course you know as in anything in
neuroscience reproducibility as a major
issue and i do think it's important to
compare results to existing analysis
methods you know one of our early
iterations of the variational
autoencoder encoder
was great at giving us principal
components which we could get out of a
standard pca analysis
so
you know i think there's no need to use
a fancy machine learning tool if you
have something that's simpler and more
interpretable that will work
now the last thing i want to show is
that you know i said we need to tie
these things to multimodal experiments
and so we're trying to
walk the walk
and
what we are doing is setting up
simultaneous measurements of optical
excitation
inhibition and then fmri
and the goal is to take that wilson
cohen model that we've used and that
we've shown we can learn excitatory and
inhibitory currents from
and test
the activity that we actually measure
optically from genetically targeted
indicators against what we predict from
the resting state fmri acquired at the
same time now we're still working on
this it's technically challenging but i
think it's the right kind of goal to
strive for
and i think the the mere fact of forcing
your machine learning approach to
learning something interpretable
uh opens the opportunity for doing this
type of validation
so i just want to end with an
acknowledgement to my lab especially
amrit kashyap xiaodi zhang who did a lot
of the work that was presented in this
talk
including along with them a former
student jacob billings who is a postdoc
now in czech and did a lot of work on
the t-sne representation
thank you very much for listening and i
look forward to our discussion